Speaker 1: So we just had another election here in
the United States a couple of weeks ago. And one
would imagine that around now would be the time
for Republicans to start unveiling some specific
examples of voter fraud that supposedly happened
across the U.S. in these 2022 midterms. And it's
because they've been focusing on it nonstop as
an issue for their party. They've also started
a bunch of state level law enforcement units that
were set up to investigate specific voter fraud
instances. And so one would think that with this
being their first opportunity to unveil the truth
about double voting by Democrats and Democrats
voting for their dead grandma and people putting
the wrong kind of sauce on the ballot and all
these different things, you'd think that they
would be talking about this stuff nonstop, but
actually they've been very much hush hush. And
that's because in Florida, Georgia and Virginia,
where these election fraud agencies were created,
all backed by Republicans, they just don't
have the examples to put forward to people.
And it shouldn't be much of a surprise that
they're coming up short, because we know and
we've known this whole time that voter fraud
is incredibly rare in the United States. Every
study that we have on this, the Brennan Center of
Justice Study, for example, show that it's like
a handful of cases out of billions of votes cast
across many, many different election cycles that
you have someone who's provably committed fraud.
And many of the examples of voter fraud from the
2020 election were actually Republicans who were
voting for Trump, thinking that they were making
up the difference because the left was supposedly
committing so much fraud. Surprise, surprise,
they weren't. But the Trump people in some cases
were. And of course, voting twice. Voter fraud
in general is just rare because it's the type
of thing that could get you sent to prison and
you're risking potential jail time for one vote.
That's probably not going to make the difference
in an election. It's probably going to end up
being inconsequential. So it just doesn't seem
like a fair trade for the average person to want
to make. That's why when DeSantis wanted to do
his voter fraud stunt earlier this year and find
people to charge an arrest for for voter fraud,
he had to choose people who thought that
they actually were able to legally vote,
thought that they had their rights restored from
the ballot measure in Florida back in 2018 on
restoring felon voter rights. And it's only these
fringe cases that you can really find to really
make your case for how this is supposedly existing
all across the country. There's just not that many
cases of people willingly doing this. And so a
special task force in all of these states never
really made sense. But of course, it was just
to appeal to right wing voters. But even so,
they're not succeeding at doing that because
they're not able to come up with at least just
a couple of cases to parade out to people and say
that this is systemic across the entire country.
It's only been a couple weeks, so maybe we'll
just have to give them more time. But sadly,
Republican voters will just look at this all. And
even if there's a lack of evidence, they'll say,
oh, see, that means that Democrats have gotten
especially good at rigging the elections because
they can cover their tracks so easily. And it
means that we have to pour even more resources
into trying to catch them. I will say, though,
that the voter fraud thing does seem like it's
calming down after this 2022 midterm cycle. The
only person that's really trying to make it a
focal point is Carrie Lake, who lost her election
in Arizona. But these other Trumpian candidates,
like Doug Mastriano and Tudor Dickson in Michigan,
they've just decided to concede. So at least for
now, the voter fraud lies are taking a break. But
I do think that they'll be back in 2024 if Trump
decides to run and if he ultimately ends up losing
either the primary or the general. So they're
taking a break from this narrative now, but you
better believe it's probably going to come back.